y los modos lo ha hecho oficial después
de que sus abogados presentarán una
carta acusando a túnez de frustrar
activamente sus solicitudes de más
información el ceo de tesla vuelve a
amenazar con abandonar su oferta de 44
mil millones de dólares para comprar
twitter si no consigue la información
que quiere su petición conocer la
cantidad de spam y cuentas falsas que
operan en la plataforma estas cuentas
conocidas como bots se gestionan a
menudo de forma anónima y mediante
inteligencia artificial interactuando
con los tweets y difundiendo información
errónea twitter es consciente del
problema y en sus declaraciones al
gobierno estima que alrededor del 5 por
ciento de sus 229 millones de cuentas
son spam sin embargo más cree que la
cifra es mucho mayor y en mayo tuiteó
que al menos el 20 por ciento son falsas
el multimillonario afirma que la
metodología de las pruebas de twitter es
poco rigurosa y que quiere realizar sus
propios análisis lo que requiere
información adicional que la plataforma
aún no ha facilitado hubiera respondido
diciendo que ha compartido todos los
datos relevantes y que la intención de
cerrar la transacción y hacer cumplir el
acuerdo de fusión al precio y los
términos acordados desde que hemos que
empezó a hablar sobre las cuentas de
spam el mes pasado las acciones de
twitter han caído un 20% lo que ha
provocado una demanda de los accionistas
que acusan a moscú de desinflar el
precio de las acciones los analistas
dicen que moscú podría estar buscando
renegociar los términos del acuerdo o
desecharlo por completo pero si se aleja
podría enfrentarse a una cuota de
ruptura de mil millones de dólares